okay that's not gonna work oh no no
oh there he is there he is
look at that nice stash
mustache i can't get away with that a
little shorter than i thought
he gets haircuts he gets a cut who cuts
his hair
welcome back to new rock stars this is
our reaction to the mandalorian season 2
episode 7 chapter 15
the believer you guys eric is like
doing so much right now you guys saw the
star wars news and the marvel news
and oh god there's like there's news i
haven't even told him about yet because
he will quit on the spot so i'm filling
it uh
i'm phil molina filling in i can't i
don't even know my own damn name
i'm sorry i know that you guys want eric
but let the boy
play let the boys play this is wikileaks
our mandalorian after show
brought to you by our good friends at
manscape which i do every week with
their products and again i'm bill belina
and this is tommy bechtold
yes let them play let them play
let them play god i need a manscape i'm
looking over here i got some action over
here i don't love
i've got some action over here i've got
wizard brows coming out
i need a manscape i need a landscape i
need to escape from whatever hell i'm in
right now
that is not allowing me to groom myself
we'll get into uh some manscaping those
revealed on this episode of the
mandalorian by the way uh
later in the episode when we go real
deep into he took off his helmet
and what we think about that that'll be
uh near the end of the episode but a
quick reminder to get your limited
edition this is the way shirt exclusive
from the new rockstars official merch
storage rockstarsmerch.com
guys finally we are down to the last 200
shirts we kind of
we sold a lot of these shirts but again
because it's a limited edition
we're gonna kill it even though we're
like people seem to enjoy the shirt
so it's either going to sell out first
or on december 20th
boom it's gone forever limited edition
uh latest obsession number one
can no longer be gotten so if you're
trying to do the
collectibles where you know number two
is coming up soon after
a hint it's a marvel shirt then you need
to get number one right now also by the
way just throwing out there the little
baby grogu shirt it's your last chance
to grab that one too
that one as soon as it sells out we
won't be reordering because it scares us
to be selling that shirt at all
yeah my this is the way shirt arrived in
the mail this week but
since my mom bought it for me as a
christmas present she won't let me have
it until christmas so
i was planning on wearing it today but
she's taking a hard line so you're just
gonna have to
tell me and she didn't even order me a
shout out
speaking of shout outs uh you can add a
shout out whenever you order
latest obsession shirts and actually uh
2.99 i'm gonna read from some shout outs
but as i'm pulling the shout outs up i'm
gonna call out that tommy we would have
given you a shirt for free
i was happy to support no you weren't
your mom did it
well you know i made her support it was
a it was uh what what do you call a
symbiotic relationship
she gave me life and i have given her
massive debt um
this is the way yes uh okay so quick
little shout outs here that are
fun i'm gonna point out some we've got
happy birthday to swap nika
um and also oh this is nice uh gerald
reynolds iii
one good thing to come out of this
year's the binge time with his sons toby
and gabe
that is really nice i think there's so
much stuff and i started doing this
crazy thing where i started
noting every single show i've ever seen
i've seen over 300 television shows
uh and like half of that's been in
quarantine yeah those are some good
stats
how do i want to do that i think mine
would just make me sad yeah no it's a
crazy
waste of time mine is all coaching
murphy it's all coke coke
it's all coked up it's a lot of south
park
i can't really in 28 days
also happy birthday to douglas andrew uh
i i don't know the baseball player's
name so it's pronounced like the
baseball player but i don't
don't know how to say it white hodges
shout out congrats to uh anisha and
anton on your engagement from zack
real quick there's what i gotta call out
here because she has the best name
i love this message from uh to john tan
um
uh but it's thanks for sharing your love
uh star wars manly with us but it's from
zara tan
who sounds like the most star wars-y
character
yes zara tan i served under her in the
clone wars
yeah yeah exactly i remember she uh
hershey's guilty of many war crimes
uh if sorry i think sartan is a mom out
there but doesn't mean she can't be
guilty of
war crimes no uh and then finally mois
coitus this is the way
uh moth coitus is also a grandmother oh
my
[Laughter]
oh god much better than grandma's coitus
we will now show you the power
of a fully operational moist coitus oh
moist one of the worst words in the
english language yes tommy
yeah it's time to get a recap of this
episode
what happened recapping that's the
that's the jingle i just came up for it
worry capping
uh don't love it well it's a work in
progress we'll workshop it uh
this may be the most morally confusing
episode of the mandalorian i'm not sure
that we were the good guys they're
rooting for the good guys at any point
we'll get into that
cara dune remands the mandalorian's old
enemy migs mayfield played by my close
personal friend bill burr in her custody
to acquire the coordinates
don't take your calls no does it cause
has no idea who i am uh coordinate to
moth gideon's ship
mayfield directs them to a hidden
imperial
rhidonium refinery on morack which we
were told was
an empty wasteland no no no my friend
the empire has a secret little shack up
in there
q anon was right yes right when they
arrive
uh the mandalorian elects to accompany
mayfield into the refinery in order to
access a terminal and steal
the coordinates as all the others are
known to imperial security
kind of a funny like i can't go moment
in the show where they were all like i
can't go for this reason i can't go for
this reason and then uh
mando is like well no one knows who i am
because i never take my helmet off
so mayfield in the mandalorian hijacking
imperial transport disguise themselves
as soldiers
they barely survive attacks by pirates
who detonate
highly explosive rhidonium shipments and
uh
they're able to just barely get out
alive when for the first time in my life
i uttered the phrase
wow thank god the tie fighters showed up
which was again
a confusing moment and they get to the
facility and they find the main terminal
mayfield sees his former commanding
officer valen hess
a great star wars name and fears being
recognized could you imagine if they
kept showing that guy's face and like
and they just never acknowledge it and
they're like that guy's weird that extra
really formed an opinion he gave he was
he was looking at him like he was a
steak he was like lying him up and down
the editors like we're trying to edit
around it but this guy is in every shot
it's so expressive is that grand moist
coitus we haven't seen him since elderon
erupted
in a shattering orgasm it's orgeron
collided with alderaan
uh orgytron is a robot that i built
so so the middleweight says i got this
he goes in
to the terminal but oh no the terminal
requires a facial scan well that
is the way he lifts off the helmet
shows us that beautiful beautiful face
we've been waiting a year to see
because you can't google pedro pascal
you can't it's cheating well you can't
google the
guy who actually plays the role yes it's
not john wayne's grands
uh grandson who actually is in the suit
uh that's a true fact
that's a true fact that's a true fact i
told you i didn't just make up a weird
thing
uh he's confronted by hess and i kind of
enjoyed
like a stammering mando like he was like
i don't really know how to answer this
question so i'm just going to kind of
figure out which one of my cool weapons
to use but it doesn't have a suit so
the truth is pedro pascal has never
recorded a scene for the show in his
life he did not know he was in a star
wars show
they drop him in that's a true fact
they're just he's just like
all right and do i say in my name mando
or
or david my baby or pedro
my baby yeah and then so bill burr's
like [ __ ] i got this i look like
brown eyes he's coming in it's hot out
here they cut out all the times he kept
saying like i'm like cgi though right
like they're not gonna like see me
just as long as they don't see this face
okay so uh he's confronted my house
mayfield intervenes and kind of one of
the more enjoyable uh scenes i saw
and then hess says let's get a drink
boys so they have a tense drink where
hess basically insinuates that not only
does he not know who mayfield is but he
doesn't know who any of the soldiers
are they're just bodies and a means to
an end for him they reminisce about
operation
cinder which sends uh mayfield into such
a ridge that he shoots us
dead uh creating one of those great
insurmountable star wars moments where
it's like two versus two thousand
luckily the 2000 can't shoot so it
doesn't ever matter
they are wearing the helmet that's true
if you've ever seen
their their visor line yeah it's like
right here it's not conducive for for
marksmanship
could you imagine uh if they like take
off their helmets and every
stormtrooper's eyes are like over here
they're just like they're like
amphibious like hammerhead people they
do those weird sideways blinks for men
in black
okay so may failed in mandalorian they
have to fight their way out we go
introduced to what i'm going to dub the
wilhelm whale
it's like a wilhelm scream but like two
stormtroopers fall and they go
ah
it was much more of a whale than a
screen
i'll have what she's having and uh
they're they're also they get a nice
assist from
fennick and cara dune who are shooting
from up in the hill
uh and then of course the man the myth
the legend boba fett comes in to drop
another two for one
uh grenade kill on two tie fighters
which was truly another incredible
segment what a time
it only took 40 years but we now are
finally getting to see boba fett
traversing the galaxy and the slave one
being a complete badass
so as i said fed obliterates them dune
and and mando kind of agree to let
mayfield go as a thank you for all of
his help
and uh mandalorian then sends moff
gideon
uh what i like to call a cover song he
covers moff gideon's hit from the first
season of basically reiterating the
message from moth about how
he means more than him than you'll ever
know and he vows to rescue young grogu
which of course i will still only refer
to you
as baby yo-yo from this point on and
then the credits roll
god beautiful you know you just reminded
me this moment with boba fett it was
very cool but also
one of my favorite moments of boba fett
was just that subtle thing where he's
like uh
yeah they might recognize me and he
doesn't mean like
because i'm boba fett he means there was
a time when
every single person in the empire that
was under these helmets
looked exactly like me right like
literally like
every every single one of anyone is like
holy [ __ ] that's the guy we're all based
on wait a second
not now but still could you imagine
there's like this like uh war
war memorial wall where it's just like
all the great generals from the
stormtrooper days and they all look
exactly like his father
employee of the month for like 25
straight years
is just like him going up there that's
great so much mean but they're all
different ones
yes great episode a lot of great moments
in it uh
again i think the thing that was the
most jarring for me though was at the
end of that great pirate chase scene
when the tie fighters show up and you're
like
whew and then you realize like oh
i've been conditioned to be afraid of
everything i'm seeing right now and they
came for the wrong guy and they even
changed the music it was still very like
imperial but it was much more like
heroically appear like it was still like
those like baseline bass drum popping
circumstances
right but it was much more like this is
the good guys now
as they're all celebrating it was a
bizarre bizarre moment
for me yeah my favorite thing so the guy
who directed this also wrote it and he's
written
um a couple of feature films that are
like complicated about like diverse
backgrounds and and
you know what it means to be who you are
and part of a larger group
um so you definitely bring those themes
in there and i think that
uh one of the best things a writer can
do and it's so rare that they
they do this but it's that whatever the
characters are experiencing on screen
you try to find a way to make your the
viewer
feel literally the same feelings so they
literally are empathizing in that moment
with the character because they feel it
and so that's what you're going through
in that moment where you're feeling
like thank god for tie fighters yeah and
that's not a thing that we should ever
feel no
but that's what the characters are also
going through and it's such a
complicated question
yeah but uh overall i i thoroughly
enjoyed this
good i'm glad that you you uh you keep
you're going to stick with this show
what i'm giving it one more hour i'm
giving it 17 episodes
uh tommy i want to get into uh uh some
people
were i just was looking to see what
people were saying about this episode
and some people
were saying that it actually uh was like
a bit of a filler episode
and i want to get into the deeper
meaning of this episode
because to me this was in some ways
maybe a filler episode for the plot of
the mandalorian yeah but in some ways it
was kind of like the most
important story ever told in star wars
yes let's get into it baby because i
don't disagree with you okay you need to
snort your adderall real quick
it's already in there i keep it
preloaded it's like a double barrel
shotgun it's already in there
if it's good enough for the president
all right so
i'm talking about joe biden yeah of
course i'm kidding remember when
when trump accused uh biden of like he's
like he did really good in that debate
only because he clearly like you know
did adderall or something that's like
man are you guilty of nothing like every
time it's something that is so specific
to you
i don't know if biden's hair is real i
gotta be honest i suspect that his hair
is
uh is manufactured in a lab yeah has
issues
also i think he might be rich he also
accused him of golfing too much which
was a truly an incredible moment
this is all this is the deeper meaning
real quick i'll say i have nothing
against adderall i
very much need it i have a prescription
that i am very happy
about uh because it means i can do all
of these things speaking of
doing uh things i do on adderall is
looking too intensely into star wars
okay so let's get into it
the episode was called the believer and
i think that um
it's trying to contrast the role of the
believer with the role of the zealot
um which you know religious zealots or
even
like socio-political zealots sort of
it's people that uh
believe uh wholeheartedly without
consideration of context and perspective
um and paradigm
so this the concept of a believer is
is pre like before the the level of
zealot where
maybe you it's you do have strong
beliefs but you're still willing to
question them
and i think that's what this episode is
really trying to get everyone to do is
question their beliefs
so then this is happening again because
the director was the same person as the
writer
um and is going for a lot of like
metaphor here
it's happening in very literal ways and
it's happening in kind of subtextual
ways
but it's all about the shades of gray
and i think there's a reason why
our heroes were wearing gray trooper
armor for the whole episode
because it really wanted to call out
like no we're not going to put them in
the traditional white
we're not going to put them in like you
know death trooper stuff or whatever
we it's just a subtle way and people a
lot of times think i'm bullshitting
about star wars colors but star wars
is the most color color-based thing ever
in archetypes
every lightsaber has a color meaning if
the jedi being
in shades of brown it all is color-based
um but so it's about that right the
shades of grey it's about
the concept of hiding behind armor in
general
and it's about the concept of an
anonymity associated with that
so like i was saying some people saw
this episode very much as a side mission
um which a lot of the episodes i made
really can feel like uh but
what i was saying earlier i think this
was like a thesis
level response to one of the most famous
questions ever posed against the star
wars universe
are we sure we are the good guy right
right probably most famous uh in in
kevin smith's clerks
he they're talking about the destruction
of the second death star
which is like you know still underway uh
and his character points out
wouldn't there have been thousands of
independent contractors
on an unfinished battle station aren't
those
innocent victims of left-wing militants
i
i remember when that question was first
posed in clerks i was pretty young but
that blew my mind
uh i was like oh yeah of course you
start crying yeah you're like oh right
there was a guy
that was putting in windows and like you
know it's like the glass guy
on the death star that like was like
honey i got the
i got the contract for the death star we
could retire after this and then he's up
there
he's up there and a millionaire he's the
old couple from the beginning of up
that's why she died a broken heart he's
a ghost
a force ghost so this episode was
exploring that question from the outset
of the episode like right away at the
beginning even when kara dune
um starts the episode she's not defying
the empire
when she's breaking mayfield out she's
defined the new republic right
and they're teaming with a criminal and
yet we're
on the side of good right yeah but
really the the themes of the episode
become
really clear when uh like tommy
described that moment when mando
has to wear the helmet of a storm
trooper that is about as close to being
walk a mile in another man's shoes as as
you could ever get
it's literally another guy's helmet
mayfield actually calling out
uh the the guys like wet gloves was
really
hilarious and gross to picture and like
you could just like hear it almost like
but it's actually to call out the
humanity
inside of that armor right that it's
reminding you these are real people that
sweat and bleed and believe in things
inside of those suits but sticking with
the helmet per sec
so that is the most literal metaphor for
what this entire show
the mandalorian is getting to and it's
is it possible for this
cowboy bounty hunter to be on the side
of good
and that's really a freaking question a
lot of westerns in general and the show
is really inspired by a lot of westerns
so let's talk really quick about helmets
in star wars
they have always represented anonymity
and
unquestioned faith like being a believer
and probably the best examples of that
are
are one the the white stormtrooper
helmet with completely empty eyes
that's meant to be the image of an
anonymous foot soldier uh
literally they don't have names and they
make them all identical
in this way that removes removes any
sense of identity
then you have like uh luke who's being
challenged to give into his faith fully
by obi-wan so ob
asks him to lower the blast shield on
his helmet literally blind himself
don't worry about what your eyes are
telling you just believe which is some
total brainwash [ __ ] completely
agree i mean that's like when you took
me to the batting cages and made me put
my
sweatband over my eyes and you said just
stand in the center of the cage
and believe in yourself right and then i
beat you with a bat
yeah yeah into submission yeah
and now i work here uh and then the
third biggest example of that that helm
helmet idea is also darth vader clarion
you know and it's all black easily
archetype uh the most clear archetype of
a bad guy ever
but finally finally when he returns to
the side of good it's the only time we
ever see him in the original trilogy
remove his helmet you know we actually
get to see his face and his humanity is
restored
uh so this show and this question is
asking who are you
underneath the helmet behind the armor
that's
why there's so much focus on the armor
on the show and while mayfield does a
good job of equating mando's armor to
stormtrooper armor
there is a hint that mando's blind faith
is actually a little more solid uh than
the stormtrooper one when we see
in that fight with the pirates uh and
the the imperial armor like falls apart
so easily
uh but famously we know best car would
never uh have any issues there
right so it's it's a more solid faith um
and that's being equated with the armor
but that also does not mean that
mando is more morally correct right it
just means that
you actually have to assess him by his
actions
more than by his edict i've found uh
a lot of that compelling in this episode
that bill burr played such a
what's the right word for this devil's
advocate almost of like i understand
that you think it's this
but don't you see how we're not that
different from each other like that
whole speech was like
you think that because you wear this
armor and this helmet and have this code
that you're this superior being to me
but in actuality
our impulses and our in our and our
desires are not that differently aligned
yeah in
in the simplest way we can say don't
judge a book by its helmet right
and so there is a way to to properly
judge it though right the right way to
do it
if you are fully anonymous then then how
do you judge it
and it's also it's the classic invisible
man question
right if you could get away with
anything anonymously
what would you do tommy what would you
do if you were an invisible man
oh man how do i answer this without
having people on twitter call me a creep
i would just sit in barnes noble and
read
just don't be a creep i would read all
the books i would just
read books and never pay for books that
would be my one vice
so i'd never buy a book again only you
would know that you're fully nude in
barnes and noble oh
again i would never work i mean i'm
already to the point where i won't put
on anything that requires buttons or
zippers
but i could go the next level and just
never wear clothes again
yeah except for uh that [ __ ] mask i got
you yeah we had to do a
uh like shoelace string on the front
instead
yeah you had to reinforce that because i
was so persistent
yeah um but or another way to think of
it actually that is maybe a little bit
easier to perceive rather than the
invisible man theory
because that's kind of like the silly
alternate reality but what about you
viewer and you tommy and me phillip
what kind of internet commenter are you
right do you hide behind the
anonymity of the internet and say things
that you would never dream of saying
if they were tied to your actual name or
maybe you're the kind that i don't need
credit for when i say good things and i
just want to add
positivity right both of those are
extremely possible on the full spectrum
of that sure
my preferred commenting is something
really really mean
and then as soon as the person responds
i say actually i'm just a really big fan
of yours and
i was just kidding your attention it was
all a big joke i didn't mean the things
that i said that caused you to
respond to me my bad i'll give you a
quick note that um
i i handle our lower merch customer
service or a lot of it uh
and people's incoming uh messages are a
lot meaner than when they're like
oh you're actually seeing this okay um
i'm sorry i was so mean to a stranger
but it's like right
the other person we had at one point
helping with customer service was this
55 year old woman yeah it was just like
like a mom and she was like oh god also
be nice to everybody
not okay not to not to dive too deep
into customer service but
we're conditioned to be like you have to
be kind of blunt with customer service
for these bigger corporations to have
them do anything to help you
like if you call delta airlines and are
like super nice to them
they will get you off the phone with no
resolution in 10 minutes but if you call
delta airlines and swear at them and say
i'm not this is unacceptable i'm going
to like lose my mind
then you have a chance of them helping
you which is so screwed up and
of our society that we don't reward you
know kindness and empathy
when i call any major corporate airline
i keep hitting
zero and say speak to a human speak to a
human or whatever but even if it is a
human yeah
until i'm like and they're like i am a
human and i'm like no you're beneath
yeah i mean a manager send me a blood
sample i need you to expedite me a blood
sample i'll stay on the line
yeah exactly i'm like really if you're a
human
which one of these is full of motorcycle
pictures huh
and they're like this isn't a visual
phone call and i'm like
sounds like a bot click on the chimney
you bastard uh
there is a yeah uh anyway i would like
that refund
yeah um so and and speaking of this idea
of face identity and really being true
to assessing ourselves
uh that's a big reason of why i made it
so that on under rock stars
we would be the channel that wouldn't be
afraid to put our faces on camera a lot
of people that cover what we cover
uh never show their face on camera and i
was like no we're definitely gonna show
it because one i am very very vain
but two aside from that we put our faces
to our words and
be and we write our scripts because we
are the ones saying it
and we're saying yes this is us we are
not always right
but we are pretty much always honest and
authentic to what we believe
and we're gonna sign that with our big
ugly faces
and so the brilliant writing moment
in the episode is uh when mando has to
freaking take off his helmet for the
greater good and i call it brilliant
because they tied remember i was talking
about trying to bring things and make
them happen
kind of at the same time they tied the
breaking of the most significant rule
that we know that mando lives by
to the literal metaphor for unmasking
yourself and revealing who you really
are like that's just writing
uh but now something worth noting there
is a
big distinction between the troopers
that we see
around who aren't taking their helmets
on and off other than literally just
mayfield amanda the only ones we see
kind of actually do that
and the imperial officers those are the
ones we do see their faces right
it's one of the most obvious connections
in cinema that the empire is based on
the nazis and the imperial officers are
modeled
after hitler's ss officers but
i'm gonna argue that this episode
actually is
not making that case i think it's saying
the empire is
america oh and why is that
note okay there's a couple of like
little clues for that well i
it was like kind of what you were
talking about how it made you feel and
some it's because these little tricks
that were being done for instance
all the saluting that was going on we
almost never see that kind of saluting
on in star wars yeah
uh and if we did maybe it would have
been more like the nazi style salutes
you know we we famously saw that was in
in force awakens where it
basically is nazi style saluting this
was like a traditional american style
military salute also exactly that tie
fighter moment they come in and it feels
like freaking top gun
or like the guy the plane's coming in to
save the day at the end of saving
private ryan
uh and probably the most obvious
connection that i saw that was i think
is definitely on purpose was when
valentine
says everybody thinks they want freedom
but what they really want is order and
when they realize that
they're going to welcome us back with
open arms they're going to welcome
us back with open arms that's almost
exactly what dick cheney said
to the iraq war we will in fact be
greeted as liberators
how did that turn out by the way uh uh
not great
not great no you made a lot of money but
for most people
my uh my independent contracting company
uh backtech
we're still in there installing uh dirt
what we call dirty wells
you you took down saddam's palace uh
replaced it with just one
terrible well yeah uh but okay even even
uh just keeping the connections there
alive to american military history
even when mayfield is going on his rant
there and he's reminiscing about
operation cinder
that's not based on you know like the
famous example of a nazi soldier doing
that
that's coming from the idea of like a
traumatized vietnam
questioning why he even was sent to war
in the first place
so i'm not saying that the empire um has
always like actually been based on
america is definitely the nazis yeah
but this episode is arguing that it's
kind of
organized military force in general
could be the empire yeah and so it's
important for the believers
to question their beliefs like mando is
now questioning like
mayfield has previously questioned right
in his history
when you're following other people's
orders how do you know if you are the
liberators or the persecutors
how do we know where the good guys right
and again
that is the most classic star wars
questions
are the rebels actually terrorists and
this
episode finally gave us the answer to
that question
finally i don't i don't have that answer
philip what are you trying to
give me to commit to that the rebels are
terrorists maybe that's what the
question
of the episode is right but it all comes
down to that scene
where they're having drinks yeah and if
you replay that scene
that is someone on officially answering
first star wars
the art of rebels terrorism yeah and
here's how it goes based on the
conversation over drinks with valentes
we can examine what is meant by saying
uh
something is an act of terrorism all
terrorists
kill innocent people yes but not all who
kill
innocent people are terrorists right the
difference lies in the
intention of the person doing the
killing if the death of an innocent
person was
the goal or the means by which you
you are trying to accomplish your goal
then you are a terrorist
if the death of innocent people was
unintended
then you're not even though your actions
could still be morally wrong
it doesn't mean you're a terrorist so
balance describes the
next steps of the empire with literal
glee
about the destruction and chaos that
they're going to bring yeah
and how does that differ from when kevin
smith brings up the idea of the rebel
attack on the death star of two
you can use the history of the first
death star the first battle station to
go by
the rebels can be confident that an
unmolested death star 2
is going to go on a genocidal killing
spree
and destroy dozens of planets so the
rebel attack in that situation therefore
is
saving billions of lives and is
therefore an appropriate and
proportionate response
so anyone who's ever been worried about
this little little baby tommy back in in
the sixth grade
you can breathe easily because they are
saying yes the rebels
are the good guys they're the good guys
we ourselves
might not be yeah we got to question
everything i'm definitely a bad i'm a
bad good guy
yeah and and but you mentioned bill burr
earlier and i think you're right like
that dude's main thing in all his comedy
is like
we are all hypocrites yeah so tommy
that's my argument for why this is
this was not a bs episode that this was
actually a huge statement
inside of star wars i don't i don't i
didn't take this as a bs episode to get
i understand why on the surface it's
like well they didn't get any closer
plot wise it didn't make a leaps and
bounds
with every second which we've had the
last few episodes have been like
every two minutes another plot point
uncovered every two minutes another
x on the map on our on our destiny to
get to the end of the quest
this one was more like here is a
bunch of information and emotion about
the world of these characters and how
they live and how like
what they really are about and what they
really stand for
and it more clearly defines the good
versus evil
and that definition is very complex yes
absolutely right
what are you wearing well it's not just
green lightsaber versus red lights by
the way
what are you wearing i am wearing
buffalo bills clothes
ah this is the way the free advertising
you give to
a billion dollars to a massive
corporation sports
organization yeah all right uh speaking
of
uh get your shirt yeah we're we're all
billionaires my new rockstar stock is up
like nine half thousand points today
speaking of
us helping corporations uh because they
help us back
tommy we gotta give it up to helix sleep
oh baby do i love helix
tommy you legitimately sleep on a helix
mask that's right
me and myself and i every night sleep on
a helix mattress
oh threesome it's a threesome every
night with me that's what they say i'm
eating for three
sleep can be hard enough when you're
staying up way past midnight
to watch the latest mandalorian episode
the second it drops
and you don't need to make it harder by
sleeping on a saggy old mattress
don't go to sears and buy a mattress
that's what your grandparents did and
they're probably
racist helix sleep has a two-minute quiz
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
with helix you get a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way
you sleep how do you sleep tommy i sleep
rolling
around flailing wildly screaming into
the night like a
banshee which as we all know is a ghost
of sky
operation cinder gallon boss
eric boss uh yes they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot or if
you're
sleeping with another person i guess
like two sticks rubbing together gross i
can't sleep next to anyone
i prefer uh plexiglas like like a debate
uh
just a plexiglas shield that comes down
and there's even a helix plus mattress
for plus size
folks yes sir i don't have a helix plus
someone dropped the ball there i'm
sleeping on a helix minus off-screen
producer zack
recently took the quiz and failed
miserably he got an f
no just kidding off-screen producer zach
recently took the quiz it got matched
with the helix midnight which is the
sexiest name felix perfect for a side
sleeper in need of some pressure point
relief
relief and have you seen zack sleep i do
and he's a hell of a side sleeper oh my
god i would sleep next to that side
any day when you order the mattress that
best fits for you
that you're matched to they ship it
right to your door just like santa claus
for free the unboxing videos are pretty
great too
thanks to the viewers that have tagged
us in those i love watching a mattress
spring to life like a cabbage patch doll
rolling forward
unfurling itself saying lay on me lay
on me helix was awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020
buy gq and wired magazine pretty good
sources if you ask me
just go to helixsleep.com mandalorian
take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a custom
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life i took the sleep quiz
i got a 700 math
at 800 oral oh god they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
this isn't a rescue dog that bites your
nephew okay
it's a mattress that's comfortable helix
is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows those are
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
mandalorian you know uh eric got some of
those free pillows recently
uh but he doesn't know that i got them
first and i tried them out and they were
amazing and then i gave it to him
you know what else i tried out before i
gave to him manscaped
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
men actually shaved their balls with the
same
razor as their face and actually that
wasn't that long ago i wish it was just
in college but i mean
like it's my early 30s fairly recently
not anymore thanks to our sponsors of
course i manscaped they're the best
in men's below the waist grooming from
the toes to the
hose holes uh manscaped is here to help
you
keep your nether regents as clean as
boba fett's beautiful
bald head which is maybe equally scarred
uh but actually with manscape you'll get
fewer scars than
i used to get with my face razor that's
what i used to show my partner when i
would uh take off my pants you want to
know how i got these scars
and then i would make my scrotum smile
my mother was a gamer
uh anyway tommy it was a it was a mess i
it was like using a lightsaber to wipe
my ass but instead
manscaper change the grooming game with
the perfect package
3.0 inside the perfect package you'll
find an electric trimmer which i use
regularly
uh the lawnmower 3.0 is a waterproof and
skin safe trimmer which
reduces nicks i'm not going to say
eliminates them completely because one
time i tried to test these
it's the limits and i mean they exist
it's not like
the limit exists some sort of weird
thing yeah
this is the way guys to your smooth
smooth boys
uh it also includes the crop preserver
uh anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer
the crop reviver uh and the i also have
anti-chafing performance boxer briefs in
a
very sharp black color uh i honestly i
really do like that underwear sometimes
i just wear it as shorts around the
house because it's very comfortable it's
kind of like a thick fabric it's very
imperial if you will
uh get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
mandalorian and for both these shout
outs i'm going to remind people that
mandalorian with an a
after the d i know we call him mando but
man delorean m-a-n-d-a-l-o-r-i-a-n
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com may the force be with your
balls
yeah baby quick it's time for our
discussion questions
and then we're done with this bad boy
bring it home baby ready tommy you
haven't seen these before correct
no let's get it on tommy in 2003
you said that you were gonna pay me back
for the nachos we ordered yes but you
did not pay me back
disgust well phillip those were nacho
nachos to be paid back for they were
mine
never mind if we're gonna do puns i
don't want to do it sorry that was
cheesy
let me just pepper in a few more jokes
chili out phillip oh boy
oh man jalapeno supposed to know
that wasn't a pun ah let's see what else
uh
don't don't let's all just chip in a
little bit here okay
tostada okay thanks tommy um it's been
fun
i i was gonna say you you you lost me at
the beginning you won me back
and then you really just murdered it
in a good way yeah we learned that you
can murder for good this time
oh speaking of murdering for good our
discussion question number one
those pirates yes do you think that they
were actually the bad guys of this
episode and did they deserve
to die well they seem to want to stop
the empire from getting what is it the
ribenium
they wanted to they wanted to stop them
from get like the empire from thriving
with the shipment of that
unstable element however their methods
appear to be very extreme
so it's again kind of that like blurred
lines robin thicke baby
what a terrible song uh i don't know if
they deserve to die
i don't think they were good guys
because i mean they were using uh
explosives to you know to kill people
but
it definitely didn't feel like they were
trying to help
the empire so what do we say to people
like that it's tough because like
i part of me wonders if it was based off
of there was this um a couple years back
al qaeda did something really similar
where it was like a train that was
carrying some sort of thing
and they like detonated stuff on the
trade so
clearly like modeled after um kind of
terrorist actions
but that said like the only people being
hurt in that are
imperial soldiers right and it is to
stop a kind of
evil empire and so you gotta like wonder
uh like maybe those are the equivalent
of
rebels they just don't happen to look
like you know
han solo so we're just like kill him
spear him
right they also made an effort to save
each other's lives when the one loses
its balance
the other one reaches out to grab them
if they were just like nihilistic
killing machines
they would he would the one would never
have tried to save the other one you
know what i mean like they
they were actively trying to keep each
other alive i feel like
we could argue that this episode's whole
point was to teach us that it's all
about perspective and
and within that perspective like those
guys
probably weren't bad guys and we
shouldn't have rooted for their deaths
right and if we had just here's a great
example if we had just turned on an
episode of the mandalorian and never
been
no didn't know the context we would have
seen an empire
badass fighter just killing some people
that are trying to stop the empire and
we would have probably been rooting for
the other guys
right discussion question number two
what do you think is currently happening
to little baby girl grogue
he's just making tick tocks up in that
ship right now like he's like doing
little tick-tock dances but he's making
troopers behind him do the dances too
with the force
so he's just it's a lot of movements
yeah i saw him do like a an overhead
like tea
how to make good tea like tik tok yeah i
had like all this stuff laid out it was
pretty it was pretty good honestly yeah
um i sat on twitter though but whatever
so no he's just like chilling
like i actually was worried that we were
gonna see some sort of like
you know like him like tied up and like
yeah i'll never tell you
he's like yeah like oscar isaac in the
force awakens where he's like just like
laying there getting me prodded by droid
needles or i was thinking of one of the
james bond movies where they have that
really weird torture device that's like
weights on a swing and it hits his balls
yes it's like yeah it's like a weighted
rope that he
swings under yeah that was awful yeah
and so it's that with baby yoda but they
have like a little like thimble
with like some pebbles in it on a little
piece of floss
[Music]
i think he likes it uh okay we have no
idea what was happening but i'm glad to
see that yeah i don't want to ever see
him tortured
so i'm glad we didn't number three what
did you think of the face reveal moment
this is the big question of this episode
right like
what what how'd you feel about it i uh
i thought it was a great moment you know
i expected there to be a
time when he would take his helmet off i
thought this was a great kind of
exclamation point on mando will do
anything to save grogu
right like he will that his his his
real true code and his real true belief
is to protect this kid at all costs and
that this was the moment
that even something that he wouldn't do
normally like take his helmet off
is something that he doesn't really
hesitate when it really counts you know
he just doesn't oh yeah i totally
agree that like the payoff of the
concept is
is awesome actually it's like they built
this up so much and now he's gotten to a
point where
for you know this little creature that
means so much to him
it is worth the his tearing down his his
values
uh and i think that's cool i thought and
i thought he did some great face acting
you know
like it was hard for him he looked very
uncomfortable having his helmet off
i believed that this that he was a
person who did not like to have his
helmet
off like he looked like a fish out of
water yeah it's like when i
uh i was in uh you know i grew up in
miami and in florida and then i went to
go visit chicago
once and i felt like cold air touched my
skin for the first time and i was like
oh is this normal yes exactly
what is this it's a wind chill philip
it's a wind chill
i love it uh next discussion question
what do you think of him breaking his
code is that is
is this a good thing or is the fact that
he's now like he had
this honor code he's breaking it is that
actually him headed toward a dark path
or a bad path
you know i'm of two minds of this on one
hand as a viewer
i get and you know as a person i'm a
people pleaser i get really frustrated
when characters are
unwilling to waver from their like
they're like no we do it this way
stubborn characters on tv shows and
movies
drive me insane the seven in game of
thrones that whole entire plot line
i was like these people are ridiculous
and they can't be reasoned with
and i think yeah when you have a code
you tend to be unreasonable
about anything that would go against it
you know and in real life that stresses
me out people that live in black and
white and don't accept any sort of
gray area or that things can be
complicated so
i think in terms of character growth
it's a very good thing it's going to
allow him to
you know have different working
relationships with different people in
this galaxy that'll be fun that he
normally would not collaborate with that
he would be like no yeah
i'm not working with you uh so yeah for
me it's a good thing
uh the only thing that's bad is it's
like the honor of being a mandalorian or
whatever it's like
that doesn't carry as much weight you
know what i mean like his kind of like
steadfast
yeah but consistency he's recently met
mandalorians though they're full of
honor
and don't do the helmet thing so for
sure he's he
has been given almost a little bit of
permission yeah yeah i think it's a good
thing too it honors the
one of the biggest themes of star wars
which is uh the
absolutes are a bad thing right um and
that like
supreme yes supreme knows is not great
so him going from a zealot to a believer
is actually healthy growth yeah um yeah
great and then our final discussion
question
i want to ask you is how on earth could
mando have sp
sending a warning that he's coming for
baby would have been a good idea at the
end like it was cool it's like oh like
he did to him and it's threatening
but it's like oh he know he got our
coordinates our ship he's able to send
us messages and he's coming
all right uh let's do all the baby yoda
stuff we need to do right now cause he's
coming
i actually thought that this was a
really kind of cringy
part of the episode his copying moth
gideon's message and was like kind of
snarky
and weirdly tonally off of how the
mandalorian
has been which makes me think it's a
misdirection that he's doing it on
purpose
and there's a reason why like there's a
there's a
we're going to find out there's a deeper
reason why he did that that way either
another ally that we don't know about
yet that we haven't met yet there's
something that forced them to do it that
way because it just didn't
to me it was a misshapen puzzle piece in
that episode it was like wait
what when did mando get kind of snarky
and like you know like
i'm gonna show you like he's never been
like that so to me
it seems like maybe he's he's doing a
rope-a-dope
i'm glad you came up you have that idea
because that makes me feel better about
it the only thing that was a little
weird for me was like it was just a
little bit of clunky writing just on
that where he's like
you have something i want yeah and he
means more to me than and it was like
well you're treating like an object and
then a second later like a
son and also like he means more to me
than you'll ever
could ever imagine it's like oh like a
father and a son i can kind of imagine
that
it was antagonistic yeah right but i
hear what you're saying
it just to me it was when that happens i
now trust this show
that they'll pay it off in the next
episode you know rather than me writing
good writing to the people at disney
i'll leave them alone i'll leave the
people at disney alone this week
they sent you a cease and desist just
because you're annoying them they did
speaking of getting uh letters from uh
disney i won't
connect this too clearly but one last
reminder that you could this is the uh
exclusive new rockstars this is the way
shirt
available uh at our new merch store
along with a ton of other options at
newrockstarsmerge.com
also remind you that the little baby
grow goo shirt is also going away as
soon as it sells out
both of those things are going to sell
out very very soon and they're
definitely gone by the 20th
uh that's it for this episode of
wikileaks follow me at philip molina
follow tommy
tommybeck told tommy it's really fun to
do these with you um i'm really excited
for the project that we can't tell
people about yet that we're gonna do
together
me too philip can't wait for a new year
and a lot of new and fun and exciting
things to work with you always a
pleasure my friend
me always a pleasure you always a
pleasure subscribe to new rockstar to
find out uh that what that new project
is gonna
be on youtube subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcast and
leave us a nice rating and review maybe
eric by the way of course is gonna be
back with his easter egg breakdown but
also he has so many videos coming out
right now
uh send him some love on twitter at
eavos and we leave you with our favorite
goku moment of the episode
footage not found great all right guys
have a good one
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
you